we are joined now by dr anthony fauci
president biden's chief medical advisor
dr fauci good morning always good to see
you
good morning thank you for having me so
as we just mentioned the fda is expected
to authorize a booster shot today for
immunocompromised people will everyone
need a booster shot at some point dr
fauci
you know it is likely that that will
happen at some time in the future
because it is it is
it would be extremely unusual and we're
already starting to see indications
in some sectors about a diminution over
time that's durability we don't feel at
this particular point that apart from
the immune compromise we don't feel we
need to give boosters right now but
importantly
we are following this in real time
literally on a weekly and monthly basis
we're following cohorts of individuals
elderly younger individuals people in
nursing homes to determine if in fact
the level of protection is starting to
attenuate and when it does get to a
certain level we will be prepared to
give boosters to those people but from
what you just said a moment ago it is
imminent that we will be giving it to
immune compromised all right here's a
question that i've heard from a lot of
people including members of my own
family if you are eligible for a booster
shot will you need to get the same brand
of vaccine you originally received
it is preferable that you go with the
same brand if you get modernit get
moderna if fisa fisa j you will be
hearing instructions about that
from the fda through the cdc and the
advisory committee on immunization
practices so there will be guidance when
that time occurs
all right let's talk about uh pregnant
people the cdc has some new guidance
based on some new data that found that
there's no increased risk for people who
are pregnant to get the vaccine what do
you say to people who still may be
hesitant about this they may still be
worried
well the data are really very very
strong glad
if you look at the tens and tens of
thousands of pregnant women who have
gotten vaccinated there's no
safety signal of concern at all
balance that against the fact that we
absolutely know
that when pregnant women who are
unvaccinated
when those individuals get infected with
sauce kovi 2 and get covered 19 it is
very detrimental not only to the woman
herself but to the fetus so that's the
reason why the recommendation has gone
from could get vaccinated to should get
vaccinated dr fauci as a parent the
concern now my child going back to
school and especially those under 12 who
still can't get vaccinated so i'm
thinking two things when are we going to
see that approval for kids under 12 and
what should we be doing with masks in
school and those mandates
well in answer to your first question we
have been doing the studies now at the
nih together with the pharmaceutical
companies
looking at the safety and the
immunogenicity or the ability of the
vaccine to induce an appropriate
response in the children and we're doing
that in what's called an age
de-escalation way doing eleven to nine
nine to six six to two and then six
months to two years and we're getting
good data on that right now ultimately
it will be a regulatory decision by the
fda which will then go on to a
recommendation from the advisory
committee immunization practices i hope
that's within a reasonable period of
time this fall so that we can get those
kids protected
but in the meantime
what you want to do what we're
recommending is that in the school
system you surround the children with
people who are vaccinated who are
eligible to be vaccinated and that's the
reason why we want to see as many as
possible of the teachers and the
personnel in the school to be vaccinated
children who are old enough and are
eligible to get vaccinated should get
vaccinated and in the other situation
which you mentioned the children who are
not yet eligible that's the reason why
we want masking in the school for
everyone vaccinated or not because we
don't want to keep the children out of
school we know
the deleterious effects
of keeping children away from physical
presence in the school mental social
development and things like that so
we've got to balance things and that's
the reason why we feel strongly we
should be masking people to protect the
children all right dr fashion what we
all want is to change the trajectory of
the virus the trajectory we're on right
now dr anthony fauci thank you very much